on va en profiter de votre présence pour
évoquer également les classements des
universités y en a plusieurs qui sont
mentionnés les régulièrement dans les
journaux en cette période le figaro le
times higher education qui présentait la
semaine dernière le classement des
meilleures universités mondiales et pas
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines elle n'y figure pas dans ce
classement
bon ça s'explique je pouvais dire
comment cela rien c'est peu finalement
d'universal à 16h même très très peu
c'est principalement des universités
américaines et du royaume uni au sea
king
voilà donc après donc je veux parler
d'une manière générale une anti
française la bande peut-être tout par
les 250 en yvelines tôt que je crois que
c'est vrai que quand on regarde l'équipe
i télé les classements comme celui que
vous évoquez le classement comme
shanghai baston que le classement c'est
vrai qu'ils aient incité françaises ne
sont pas forcément à leur avantage mais
il faut voir aussi c'est la base des
questions explique terres qui sont
utilisés pour pour établir ce classement
qui sont pas forcément favorables aux
lancers francs 16 qu'il faut bien voir
quand même les spécificités du système
français d'enseignement supérieur je
pense que ça ne veut pas dire que les
universités en france sont moins bonnes
qu'ailleurs dans l'est de l'europe dans
le reste du monde que les adversités
américaine par exemple on compare des
choses qui sont pas forcément copains je
voulais finir sur le propos est en
france système de la recherche souffre
je pense d'une double séparation il ya
vous avez en termes de formation d'un
second expert vous avez les universités
et non sélective qui ont un rôle de sa
vie celui très important et vous avez
les écoles hyper sélectifs et de la même
manière au niveau la recherche vous avez
de la recherche dans les universités
également si dans certaines écoles et
vous avez les organismes de recherche
donc on a une certaine fragmentation on
va dire du paysage dans ce moment espéré
l'enchère et je crois que l'ambition
aujourd'hui notamment sur saint christ
et de pouvoir approcher tous ses acteurs
je crois que le rapprochement
on va dire la la disparation pour aussi
il faut être aussi là un pragmatique et
lucide faut pas vouloir tout casser ça
marchera pas il faut du temps pour les
acteurs il va travailler ensemble
partagent les choses et je crois que ça
va permettre d'améliorer de rendre plus
visible
l'activité des universités mais un
classement véritablement cet important
que l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin halloween ou
ensuite déjà l'université pour l'instant
paris saclay telle qu'elle s'appelle y
figure c'est important pour être
compétitif face au reste je vois qu'il
faut pas venir des étudiants se voient
qu'on dise des déclassements ils sont
quand même une zone importante mais en
terme de communication pour être
interactif
au regard aux yeux des étudiants qui
sont en chine ou aux états unis
donc je crois qu'il sait quelque chose
qui les intéresse quand même et donc
pour finir je parle d'identité française
au général mais sur notre site et il
faut bien avoir canyon fêté ses 21 ans
qui ont opté par ces jeunes à à
cambridge harvard et autres seront c1
voilà et c'est quand même un mode très
différente fonctionnement dans six
grands cinéastes américaines ou
anglaises qui sont hyper sélectifs pour
beaucoup de moyens ça ne changeait pas
noté nos jours profite la question des
moyens très importants donc encore
j'entendais hier en moyenne en moyenne
muscles au détail si ça vous intéresse
après le financement d'un étudiant
français dans les universités françaises
d'ailleurs si tmc et 10000 euros quand
je dis au moyen de ces je prends un défi
en licence ou en master je fais une
moyenne en licence et 5000 par étudiant
aux etats unis ces vingt mille je crains
un petit lapin et si on fait donc les si
on regarde de haut niveau français
quand je parlais de la dichotomie un
petit peu enseignement universités
classes préparatoires aux grandes écoles
dont je reviens sur licence au moyen de
ses 5000 euros par étudiant de formation
à distance et 15000 euros
vous voyez quand même donc il ya quand
même je dis pas là qu'il faut supprimer
les moyens classes préparatoires aux
grandes écoles
tout simplement que les essenciers
souffre d'un doigt un manque de moyens
donc ça c'est assez évident et dans le
contexte actuel c'est assez inquiétant
merci jean luc lahaye sert d'être venu
et donc sur le plateau ce soir pour ses
réactions et puis votre point de vue
également sur le campus paris saclay
dont on parlait au début de cette
édition je rappelle que toutes les
interviews tous les reportages d'une tv
fil 78 du 7-8 sont à revoir sur notre
site internet et a commenté sur les
réseaux sociaux consultation libre pour
les reportages merci donc de votre
présence jean-luc vestiaires on passe à
un autre sujet les réserves de sang
toujours trop faible pour faire face aux
besoins le centre de prélèvement ile de
france ouest multiplient les opérations
au plus près des populations pour
préparer à la fin d'année
donner son sang n'est pas un acte anodin
il peut sauver des vies
la semaine dernière l'établissement
français du sang d'île de france
organisait une collecte dans les locaux
de la mairie de trappes sur les civières
personnel de la commune et trappistes
pour habiba c'était la première fois une
expérience qui s'est bien passé et
qu'elle souhaite réitérer à l'avenir je
venais me donner à 200 pour les gens qui
ont besoin tant qu'on est en bonne santé
je préfère de nos gens qui ont besoin
les gens qui ont des accidents sur la
route des maladies graves
l'actionnaire en janvier mais c'est
dommage qu'ils viennent pas pu souvent
ici de notre bénévole non non pas depuis
des années 60 dont déjà dans mon droit
car en globules rouges plaquettes plasma
des dons indispensables pour permettre
la guérison de maladies comme la
leucémie ou la drépanocytose une maladie
génétique de l'hémoglobine qui nécessite
une transfusion sanguine par semaine dès
le plus jeune âge des dons qui
permettent aussi de donner des
traitements de qualité aux patients
globalement depuis le début de l'année
sur les yvelines où ce secteur dont ja
responsabilité mais essentiellement les
yvelines ça se passe très bien
parce que nous sommes au dessus d'un
objectif plus particulièrement nous
avons connu un mois de
de septembre et d'octobre pas très bon
et là cette semaine est pas bonne du
tout puisque grosso modo quand on attend
100 donneurs d'avis qu'il vienne à 95
qui se présentent et là on est plutôt au
niveau de 70 en ile-de-france 1700 dons
par jour sont nécessaires
4 dont maximum par an pour les femmes et
6 pour les hommes mais les trappistes
eux ont été généreux
ce jour-là 73 donneurs ont répondu
présent au lieu des 60 attendu